je voulais dire ça se fait pas
je prépare
le manioc soignante soit portée de trois
fois c'est pas possible
à l'arrêt l afrique non les hommes
centrale et sérieux ils sont d'ailleurs
il atteint en clôture contre l'avis
qu'il soit prêt avant de les faire tous
les plats compliqué comme ça même un
mari qui est maître d'hôtel dans sa
maison et benjamin noval et le dresser
un pratiquement typiquement camerounais
et de la région du littoral
moi je suis dans ses mains j'ai vécu
dans le mot là et c'est une région où
l'on cultive eu beaucoup d'eau les mêmes
sur les marchés de douala beaucoup d'eau
les provençaux viennent d'humour non et
aussi ceux qui viennent du littoral va
penser comme ça et en grandissant j'ai
appris à préparer et à m'améliorer au
contact des amis et tous faits tendent à
les appeler lieux divers au canada mais
bien sûr de savoir faire le rappel de
les moments passés avec ma maman avait
mes soeurs et puis même les moments
passés avec les amis lors des rencontres
de parce que généralement leur
désintérêt des funérailles des mariages
on se retrouvait pour préparer pour les
cérémonies quoi on achète des deux eaux
comme comparaison à ce nouveau match est
le parquet de dôle scdc comme des c pas
de branches de branche et tout fut
parfait et on le découpe comme ce qu'une
comme les épinards c'est quand même un
peu comme les épinards
je vais tourner la caméra on y voit un
peu d'où vient cette voie
[Rires]
alors je suis chez c est jean claude va
passer outre montréal
et puis ce plat est instance de son
enfance le lait et puis comme on peut
voir comme si c'étaient les hommes
n'entre pas dans la cuisine du cameroun
alors jargon se tient peu la région le
véhicule est en net recul au sénégal
puis à mourir vous êtes à marjah depuis
qu'on est à 8